cuando les enseñan álgebra les dan las
coordenadas x y xi y como saben x nos
dice que tanto se mueven hacia la
izquierda o derecha mientras que iu nos
dice cómo nos movemos hacia arriba o
abajo y muchas veces las coordenadas
cartesianas x y que se les llaman
coordenadas rectangulares porque nos
podemos mover en la forma de un
rectángulo pero también con las
coordenadas polares podemos representar
el mismo punto en el espacio supongamos
que para este punto para el que tenemos
las coordenadas x y la idea es que en
lugar de hablar de que tanto nos
moveremos hacia la izquierda o derecha o
arriba y abajo
veamos cómo lo podemos identificar desde
el origen dirigiéndonos en un cierto
ángulo y a una cierta distancia así
llegamos al punto y miren el ángulo en
el que nos movemos se conoce como teta y
la distancia que hay entre el punto y el
centro de la gráfica se conoce como r
incluso pueden verlo como el
adiós y observen que también se forma un
triángulo aquí podemos conocer el valor
de x y aquí el de que así que con este
pequeño diagrama podremos obtener la
forma equivalente para describir la
ubicación de este punto cuando tenemos
un cierto valor de x ideye y podemos
decir que este punto se ubica en las
coordenadas r teta porque erré nos dice
cuál es la distancia y theta es el
ángulo entonces veamos algunas fórmulas
básicas que podemos obtener a partir de
este diagrama por ejemplo a partir de
las propiedades de los triángulos
podemos decir que x es igual a r por el
coste no detecta y también tenemos que
es igual a r por el seno de teta esta es
una forma en la que podemos conocer las
coordenadas x y xi nos dan los valores
de reis teta y también sabemos que real
cuadrado es
la equis cuadrada más ya cuadrada ese es
el teorema de pitágoras y finalmente
tenemos que la tangente de teta es igual
a que entre equis ok hagamos algunos
ejemplos sencillos supongamos que
tenemos estos puntos observen que nos
los dan en coordenadas polares y
queremos graficar los empecemos con el
punto 1 como mapi entre 2 bueno una
pista es que primero encontremos el
ángulo entonces éste sería un ángulo
igual a cero y luego pasamos a pie entre
dos al colocarnos en el eje que ok y
necesitamos movernos en una dirección de
uno supongamos que es ahí entonces este
es el punto uno coma
y entre dos en coordenadas polares
primero encontramos el ángulo pi entre
dos y luego marcamos el punto sabiendo
que tiene un radio de 1 ahora vamos con
menos 2 coma y entre 4 nuevamente y
entre 4
el ángulo que es de 45 grados pero
observen que el radio es negativo miren
este es el ángulo pi entre 4 y podemos
reflejarlo en el otro cuadrante así en
lugar de estar en el primer cuadrante en
donde el radio es positivo este sería el
punto 2 y entre 4 vamos a reflejarlo y
así tenemos el punto menos 2 coma y
entre 4 ok y para el último punto
tenemos menos 1 coma y entre 2
nuevamente lo mismo ahora el ángulo
menos pi entre 2 nos guía hacia abajo en
el eje y y en lugar de una distancia 1
positiva lo reflejamos y así logramos
una distancia de menos 1 que en realidad
nos lleva al mismo punto así que una
forma equivalente de escribir el punto 1
/ 2 es menos uno menos pie entre dos así
es como podemos ejemplificar un punto
importante cuando tenemos algo en
coordenadas x
y los puntos tienen representaciones
únicas pero cuando trabajamos con
coordenadas polares hay muchísimas
formas de representar el mismo punto
incluso podemos jugar con el ángulo y el
radio y así obtener diferentes tipos de
representaciones tomen eso muy en cuenta
cuando trabajen con coordenadas polares
o que hagamos otros dos en el primero
nos dan la forma polar y nos piden que
grafique moss y que después lo
convirtamos a coordenadas x y entonces
primero necesitamos identificar el
ángulo 3 y entre 4 que sería este y nos
dicen que nos encontramos a una
distancia de 2 raíz de 2 supongamos que
es esa distancia y es muy fácil pasar de
la forma polar a la forma cartesiana
simplemente necesitamos usar estas dos
fórmulas porque conocemos el rey teta
así que solamente sustituimos entonces
tenemos x igual a r que en este caso es
por la raíz cuadrada de todos por el
coseno del ángulo que en este caso es 3
pi entre 4 si simplificamos todo esto
nos queda que es igual a menos 2 y
después ya es igual a 2 por la raíz
cuadrada de 2 por el seno de 3 pie entre
4 y al simplificar esto nos que datos
positivos entonces en la forma polar
este punto es el punto 2 raíz cuadrada
de 2,3 y entre 4 y en coordenadas x ya
podemos describirlo como menos 2,2 que
tiene sentido porque tenemos menos 12 en
x y 2 en ok vamos con el siguiente ahora
nos dan la forma cartesiana y nos piden
que pasemos a la forma polar bueno estas
son las coordenadas x y aquí tenemos
menos 1 y acá tenemos menos la raíz
cuadrada de 3 así que nuestro punto se
encuentra aquí
y ahora necesitamos saber su
equivalencia en coordenadas polar es
bueno para calcular r simplemente
podemos usar esta relación ere cuadrada
es igual a equis cuadrada más que
cuadrada y la tangente de teta es igual
a que entre x entonces el radio es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de la primera
coordenada al cuadrado que es uno más
menos la raíz cuadrada de tres al
cuadrado que sería igual a tres positivo
y así nos queda que el ratio es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de cuatro que es igual
a 2 ya conocemos el valor de r y la
tangente de teta es igual a menos la
raíz cuadrada de 3 entre menos uno que
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de tres y
entonces nos queda que el ángulo teta es
igual a cuatro pi entre tres y si
calculamos el seno de cuatro pi entre el
coseno de tres verán que es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 3
así es como obtenemos nuestras
coordenadas polares porque sabemos que r
es igual a 2 y theta es igual a 4 pi
entre 3
esta es la equivalencia polar y
finalmente me gustaría hacer dos
gráficas en la primera nos piden que r
se encuentre entre 1 y 2 entonces
básicamente nos dicen que si nos movemos
una distancia igual a 1 sin importar
cuál sea el ángulo mientras que el radio
sea 1 podemos dibujar una circunferencia
cuyo radio es igual a 1 e igualmente
cuando r es igual a todos
simplemente obtenemos un círculo más
grande y finalmente sombre amos el
espacio que hay entre esos dos que son
todos los posibles valores y ahora nos
piden que grafique mos todos los ángulos
que se encuentren en un rango de pie
entre 4 a 3 pi entre 4 y el radio debe
estar entre menos uno y uno entonces
primero vamos con el ángulo
este sería el ángulo pi entre 4 y por
acá tenemos el ángulo 3 pi entre 4 y
observen que obtenemos un pequeño arco
circular y toda esa región son los
valores que podríamos obtener cuando
tenemos un radio con un valor de entre 0
y 1 pero como nos dicen que también debe
de ser negativo bueno pues simplemente
lo reflejamos simplemente reflejamos lo
que ya tenemos y al graficar la otra
región nos queda algo muy parecido a un
reloj de arena espero que les sirva